presented by the boys taking the fight
to superheroes watch now only on Amazon
Prime video after 21 MCU movies prepare
for the final conclusion of the Infinity
Saga and also part 2 of infinity war
penultimate film of phase 3 entered a
phase 4 and back to a pilot for about
three Disney Plus shows who you remember
when movies just you know ended and then
your imagination had to take over Oh
sounds exhausting
Avengers and game the most successful
crowd-pleasing global film franchise is
back but since life on earth sucks now
it's all about grief loss the guild
it's supposed to be me depression are
you crying and despair that house should
have come all of us because today's
escapist fantasy is in becoming a
superhero it's going back to fix your
mistakes instead of scraping by in the
waking nightmare of your own failure did
I do it i mised on my life 5 years have
passed since half the population
vanished or as introverts call it
winning the lottery
ah that looks nice baseball remains
unpopular culture got frozen in 2017
damn and an actor shortage has forced
directors to cast themselves whom I
cried just for for dessert now
The Avengers must band together to do
what every big franchise does when they
write themselves into a corner time
travel watch the surviving heroes
dissemble for a now that's what I call
Marvel tour of your fandom with several
alternate camera angles on the Avengers
I have that drink now a trip to the
shield base where they store all the
movies closure
protect the cliffs that demand you lose
someone you love or at least your work
bestie and a daring raid to justify the
existence of Thor the dark world in
applaud held together by a whole bunch
of wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey stuff
they'll try to explain 100 times either
it's all a joke or none of it is none of
it's a joke now explain yourself if you
travel to the past that past becomes
your future and your former presence
becomes the past which can't now be
changed by your new future they'll
explain it again with a visual aid the
Infinity stones create what you
experience as the flow of time remove
one of the stones and that flows splits
no explain it again but simpler they're
not trying to stop something I'm going
to do in our time we're trying to undo
something I've already done in there's
even simpler changing the past does it
change the future you know
maybe time travels a paradox no matter
how it gets justified Z reunite with all
your favorite Marvel heroes who aren't
clogging up an air filter somewhere like
Iron Man who's really matured since Iron
Man 1 but a steal the a-hole who'd
rather die to let someone else get the
last word I am in heaven appalled
[Music]
Iron Man Captain America who after
spending a decade in the present day has
learned to curse son of a [ __ ] you got
me why and look at guys butts that is
America's and Thor who it's okay to make
fat jokes about because he's also
suffering from a very realistic
post-traumatic stress disorder what do
you think is cool seen through my veins
right now she's with he's struggling the
Hulk who cut down on the runtime by
finishing his art before the movie
starts
I know it's crazy Hawkeye who deals with
the loss of his family by having a very
cyberpunk midlife crisis and man who
thanks to the Internet's brain poisoning
is a letdown every time he's not inside
Thanos his ass flick me Black Widow
who finally gets a primary storyline in
one of these movies killing herself to
motivate the boys we have to make it
worth at least you can tell the passage
of time by her hair
that's something rody hoping and praying
they don't travel back before Iron Man 2
nebula who ruins the Avengers plan so
many times the most helpful thing she
does is kill nebula
and Captain Marvel who's so powerful the
movie desperately buys excuses to leave
her out the things that are happening on
earth are happening everywhere so you
might not see me for a long time until
he comes up with an excuse to bring her
in so Marvel can finally have her lead
the first all-female Avengers team-up
shot whew maybe Marvel will let them
team up together in his sequel okay
maybe they can all pose again in the
background of the Loki show remember
that owes the MCU is most complex and
motivated villain yet he did and taking
his place is old Thanos the new old
Thanos younger old Thanos you know the
version who sits unless everyone else do
other work on the stone what will you do
wait who steals his evil plans from
Spaceballs did you do to them
nothing yet go back to then just now and
do commands of faceless CGI Ori the
likes of which we have never seen before
since his last two faceless CGI armies
but whatever watching him fight Thunder
camp was the best moment of my life and
I'm including the birth of my children
guys sorry kids
you're just not worthy of my time and
attention so in a world where everyone
hates Game of Thrones now everyone's
worried about Star Wars and JK Rowling
won't stop crapping on the floor for
legacy it's a minor miracle we got a
satisfying conclusion to a global nerd
franchise now just do it again forever
or the entire film industry will
collapse no sympathy from us Disney you
did this to yourself
starring iron deficient man one punch
woman Captain klej
and hardly wait our roots
Bojack Norseman Jeremy Renner's one big
line of acting go grab your hammer and
you don't fly you talk to him go
downstairs go help they need you right
now
we need more Usos give me more Usos
Avengers Assemble
he's the ex-girlfriend
Werther's original Avenger and rat man
and time ban coming soon to Disney Plus
I love you 2.8 billion oh my god
her mobile plan is still active Clint
you gotta turn off auto pay man did this
on his trailer a cast hideous laughter
on you that's a DND spell which you'd
know by now if you watched our new
episode of fandom uncovered Dungeons &
Dragons this episode was brought to you
by the boys watch the new series only on
Amazon Prime video
you thought it was epic voice guy but it
was me do I am inevitable are grouped
I'm Mary Poppins y'all I am Iron Man oh
yeah